my name is Britta DeGroat and I'm a
junior studying music with a
concentration in piano performance it is
an honor and a pleasure to introduce the
speaker tonight John steel Gordon was
educated at Mill Brook school and
Vanderbilt University his articles have
appeared in numerous publications
including Forbes National Review
commentary the New York Times The Wall
Street Journal
he's the contributing editor at American
heritage where he wrote the business of
America column for many years and
currently writes the Longview column for
Barron's he's the author of several
books including Hamilton's blessing the
extraordinary life and times of our
national debt the great game the
emergence of Wall Street as a world
power the business of America tales from
the marketplace American enterprise from
the settling of New England to the
breakup of AT&T and an empire of wealth
the epic history of American economic
power please join me and welcoming mr.
Gordon to the podium
[Applause]
good evening I am happy and honored to
be back at Hillsdale College once again
I'm here to talk about socialism in
American history wishes to say the
history of socialism on very stony
ground socialism is by definition an
economic system wherein the means of
production are held in common that is by
the government
socialism therefore necessarily
concentrates power for while the people
might in theory own the means of
production only individuals can actually
act so socialism in all as many forms
from the democratic socialism of
post-world War to Britain to the
unspeakable horrors of Pol Pot's
Cambodia to that weird combination a
communist monarchy in North Korea means
not only economic power to the people
but economic power to fiduciaries for
the people the same people who exercise
political power and as Lord Acton
famously noted power corrupts and
absolute power corrupts absolutely
that's why in capitalist countries the
rich become powerful in socialist ones
the powerful become rich
in a socialist economy one is expected
to work for the common interest not
one's own interest but that's not easy
to accomplish for self interest is in
the living universe a force as all
pervasive and ineluctable as gravity is
in the physical one by having the means
of production in the hands of
individuals and corporations capitalism
both disperses power and takes advantage
of self-interest in other words
capitalism swims downstream for
socialism to work it has to somehow
negate self-interest it has to swim
upstream to use the analogy of gravity
again we can negate gravity that's how
we got to the moon 50 years ago and how
I got to Hillsdale College this morning
but it takes energy to do so this is why
socialist economies even on a very small
scale have only worked for any length of
time by the use of coercion that's why
the phrase democratic socialism a phrase
much in vague vogue these days is
largely an oxymoron now we usually think
of the United States as the most
capitalist of all major countries and it
mostly is while it may have been pure
coincidence that the United States was
born the very same year that Adam Smith
published The Wealth of Nations
it was a most fortuitous one Alexander
Hamilton who richly deserves the title
founding father of the American economy
was very familiar with Smith's seminal
book as were most of the founding
fathers Hamilton took its arguments very
much to heart when socialism was rapidly
evolving into a coherent philosophy
three-quarters of a century later Karl
Marx wrote in the eighteenth Brumaire of
Louis Bonaparte
published in 1852 after Napoleon the
third had seized power in a coup d'etat
that quote men make their own history
but they do not make it as they please
they do not make it under circumstances
chosen by themselves but under
circumstances directly encountered and
transmitted from the
asked but this country unlike the
European countries Marx was familiar
with had in fact precious little past to
be transmitted in 1776 we are not a
fully formed society with deeply
entrenched economic interests and a
well-developed class system in effect we
were something like a national tabula
rasa in the 1780s and 90's so more than
almost any other country in history the
United States could make itself as it
pleased in ways that deeply suited the
American character it is worth noting
that all but one of the ten amendments
of the Constitution known as the Bill of
Rights protect individuals from
excessive government power it is this
character this passion to do as we damn
well please under the rule of law that
has made this country such stony ground
for socialism now the American colonies
benefited greatly from the mother
country's benign neglect unlike France
and Spain England didn't care who went
to its colonies and indeed used the
colonies as a dumping ground for
convicted felons it was Britain's
inability to continue transporting
felons to America after the American
Revolution that led directly to the
settlement of Australia in 1788 perhaps
they should celebrate July 4th - that
meant that the population of early
America was largely made up of people
who marched to the beat of a distant
drummer unlike their contemporaries in
the poor economy of early 17th century
Britain they chose to take an enormous
chance they said goodbye to all that
they had known and came to what one
Puritan called a howling wilderness in
hopes of making a better and more
prosperous lives for themselves and
their posterity as to how big a chance
they were taking consider this in early
Virginia the death rate for immigrants
in their first year was about 25% after
that they were said to be seasoned and
their life expectancy increased
considerably and these risk taking
immigrants of course
had been coming ever since thus the
propensity for taking risk was bred into
the very DNA of this country and the
twin engines of capitalist success or a
willingness to take risk and competition
neither of which are found in socialist
economies which is why they are both uh
ninive ativ and poor even the DNA of
those felonious transport ease
a total of about a hundred thousand
during the colonial era added a certain
June say qua to the American genetic mix
that is not to say that this countries
had no experience with socialism indeed
the early English settlements in this
country were at first socialist
enterprises even though the very word
socialism wouldn't be coined until 1833
the colony of Virginia was not
established by the English government
instead it was founded by a
profit-seeking corporation chartered by
King James the first in 1606 the
Virginia Company of London the stock was
mostly owned by very wealthy London
merchants these were very savvy
businessmen but the company they founded
was in a wholly new business American
plantations and the steep learning curve
to profitability that any new type of
business necessarily entails would not
be successfully climbed in this case the
Virginia Company invested all told about
fifty thousand pounds sterling in the
enterprise a colossal sum in the early
seventeenth century when the annual
crown revenues from the tariff amounted
to only about seventy five thousand
pounds
regardless the company had collapsed by
1624 and Virginia became a crown colony
indeed the virginia company made just
about every mistake that it could have
made jamestown was cited badly
surrounded by mosquito breeding swamps
and where the water was often brackish
this led to salt poisoning during the
hot humid virginia summers but the
virginia company's biggest mistake was
to keep title to the land the means of
production the settlers were in effect
to work it as peasants for the company's
profit
but the company also told them that any
gold they found was theirs to keep or
sell the settlers that the company the
company had recruited all men in the
first year or so another mistake were
mostly what were then called sturdy
beggars by a healthy man who had no
employment and had gravitated to the
burgeoning slums of London and Bristol
along with the younger sons of gentry
families
the first group knew little about
farming and the latter was disinclined
to do hard work pursuing their
self-interest as people always do they
prefer to search for gold from which
they could profit directly of course
there is no gold to be found in the
broad alluvial plains of Tidewater
Virginia although they found plenty of a
form of mica that looked a bit like gold
they shipped it to England where it was
found to be worthless
the result was starvation the 104
settlers who had arrived in may 1607
only 38 were still alive nine months
later in December 1609 the colony had
220 settlers by spring 1610 only 60 were
still alive
one man crazed by hunger had killed and
eaten his wife he was burned at the
stake the company tried other means to
generate income they established a glass
factory for instance to take advantage
of Virginia's abundance sand and wood
but the glass could not be profitably
exported to England two developments
saved the company save the colony one
was the discovery of a cash crop tobacco
after the Indians had taught the
colonists exacting art of growing and
curing it tobacco became very profitable
indeed the second was the abandonment of
a company's policy of holding title to
the land and expecting colonists to work
it as sharecroppers indeed the company
began to use early America's greatest
resource it's infinity of land to entice
settlers they started to give every
settler who had paid his own way 50
acres of land along with 50
acres for each relative and servant
brought to the colony
thus the family of five would get two
hundred and fifty acres of land that
much good agricultural land in land poor
England would have given that family
Gentry status it was a powerful and
thoroughly capitalist incentive those
who had come as indentured servants were
also given land once they had served
their indentures
food production rose sharply and to
tobacco production soared from 20,000
pounds in 1618 to one and a half million
pounds only eleven years later the
American experiment was off and running
and Virginia's early socialist economy
forgotten early New England also which
is also settled by profit seeking joint
stock companies saw the land held in
common as well and thus saw poor results
in the Plymouth Colony despite the story
of the first Thanksgiving the harvest of
1621 had been poor in early 1622
governor William Bradford gave each
family a plot of land but he required
that quote all profits and benefits but
are not got by trade working fishing or
any other means we're to be placed in a
common storehouse so that quote all such
persons as are of this colony are to
have their meat drink apparel and all
provisions out of the common stock in
other words the settlers were expected
to work the fields to go out fishing and
hunting but the results were to be doled
out to each family according to its size
not according to its contribution of
labour the result was a very poor
harvest in 1622 and severe hunger in the
winter of 1620 223 but bradford happily
was no ideologue he could learn from
experience he wrote in his book of
Plymouth Plantation
quote the failure of that experiment of
communal service the taking away of
private property and the possession of
it in community by a Commonwealth was
found to breed much confusion and
discontent
and [ __ ] much employment which would
have been to the general benefit for the
young men who were most able and fit for
service objected to being forced to
spend their time and strength in working
for other men's wives and children
without any recompense the strong man or
the resourceful man had no more share of
food clothes etc than the weak man who
was not able to do a quarter of what the
other could this was thought injustice
the Asian graver men who were ranked and
equalized in labor food clothing etc
with the humbler and younger ones
thought it was some indignity and
disrespect to them bradford decided that
each family could grow and keep the food
they raised the change in attitude among
the settlers was stunning the women in
1622 had stayed home to tend the
children but in 1623 as bradford
explained quote the women now went
willingly into the field and took their
little ones with them to set corn food
production rose dramatically within a
couple of years the colony was able to
export a load of grain to england as
Denise the historian Nathaniel Philbrick
explained in his recent history of
Plymouth Colony quote the pilgrims had
stumbled on the power of capitalism
although the fortunes of the colony
still teetered Macarius lee in the years
ahead the inhabitants never again
starved of course New England early
turned to trading and shipbuilding given
the lack of a cash crop in New England
stony soil and long winters and those
early merchants knew all about
capitalism even though the word wouldn't
be invented for another couple of
hundred years indeed many of them wrote
at the tops of their Ledger's in the
name of God and profit for these pious
Puritan merchants saw personal economic
success as a sign of God's grace be nice
a bit lose with Warren have the same
attitude
now among the early settlers of colonial
America were many groups seeking
religious freedom and the United States
remains the most religious of Western
nations this yearning for moral and
spiritual perfection so much a part of
the American character has led to a
plethora of new american-born religious
sects such as the Church of Jesus Christ
of Latter days seventh-day Adventists
the shakers Jehovah's Witnesses and
Christian Science to name just a few of
the more successful and long-lived but
it also led to many social experiments
in a search for a new way of living
where property was to be held in common
the most famous of these projects was
New Harmony Indiana he was founded in
1825 by a wealthy British industrialist
named Robert Owen who was one of the
founders of the movement that came to be
called utopian socialism it got that
name by the way because the founders of
the movement believed that socialism
could be achieved without class struggle
but rather by example demonstrate that
society could work in a different and
better way and as with Ralph Waldo
Emerson's better mousetrap the world
would beat a path to your door Marx and
Engels dismissed this as utopian and the
term stuck Marx and Engels for once
we're right Owen put his money where his
mouth was in 1825 he bought an entire
town 20,000 acres in the southwest
corner of Indiana plus the buildings and
infrastructure from a German religious
sect that had decided to relocate he
paid 150 thousand dollars a very
substantial portion in the 1820s people
were expected to provide their own
household goods to invest their capital
and enterprises that would promote
community independence and social
equality they would work for the
community and be paid in credits at the
town's store or they could buy credits
there there were troubles from the
beginning there was a shortage of
skilled craftsmen and the community
could not produce enough goods to pay
its way Robert de lowens son of the
founder
describe the people who settled in New
Harmony quote as a heterogeneous
collection of radicals enthusiastic
devotees to principle honest
latitudinarian x' and lazy theorists
with a sprinkling of unprincipled
sharpers thrown in acid the town's
prospects he wrote that quote a plan
which remunerated all alike will in the
present condition of society ultimately
eliminate from a cooperative Association
the skilled efficient and industrious
members leaving an ineffective and
sluggish residue in whose hands the
experiment will fail of socially and
pecuniary in other words self-interest
dooms such enterprises the New Harmony
experiment had collapsed within two
years and private property an individual
pursuit came to the town now there have
been dozens if not hundreds of other
attempts to establish socialist
communities but most have failed
although there is one in Virginia on
four hundred acres of what was once a
tobacco farm that has been in operation
for more than 50 years after the Civil
War as the country industrialized at a
furious pace the wealthy wealth
inequality increased at an equally
furious pace enormous fortunes
epitomized by the 400 New York families
invited to mrs. Astor's annual ball were
piled up while industrial workers did
not get anything like a fair share of
the profits they helped create the
reason of course was that each big
industrial corporation spoke with one
voice while there often tens of
thousands of workers each spoke for
himself industrial capitalism was
something very new Under the Sun in the
late 19th century and the rules needed
to make it function fairly and well
could only be developed from experience
the stock market reforms of the
post-civil war era the invention of
independent accountants and generally
accepted accounting principles in the
1890s the Sherman and Clayton antitrust
legislation of 1890 and 1914 the
creation of the Interstate Commerce
Commission in a
1887 and the Wagner Act of 1939 were
what resulted it was a process that
would take about 50 years and of course
the reforms have needed their own
reforms over the years the Interstate
Commerce Commission for instance was
meant as a check on the unbridled
economic power of railroads but it
quickly evolved into a cartel protecting
the railroads profits and greatly
inhibiting innovation in that industry
when its rate-setting powers were
abolished in the 1970s so a railroads
and trucking firms could once again
compete by means of price the
transportation sector of the GDP dropped
from 15% to 10% as transportation is
what economists call a transaction cost
a necessary course that does not
increase the value of the product prices
of millions of products dropped as
competition forced manufacturers to
share the lower costs of transportation
with consumers it should be noted that
we are today beginning to learn what
rules are needed to properly regulate
the new digital economy we now live in
that has caused another surge in income
inequality meanwhile there were
increased calls for socialism in
American politics as a way to abate this
increasing inequality just as there are
today among the leaders of this movement
was Eugene V Debs
born in 1855 in Terre Haute Indiana he
came from a middle-class family his
father owned a small textile business
but he dropped out of school at the age
of 14 and went to work for a local
railroad earning 50 cents a day he
quickly identified with the working
class and his economic problems in the
new Industrial Age Deb's was a founder
of an early labor union the Industrial
Workers of the world remembered as the
Wobblies as well as the American railway
Union the Pullman Strike of 1894 led by
Debs after an initial hesitation was one
of a series of often violent strikes at
this time the Pullman Strike resulted in
about eighty million dollars worth of
damage and thirteen
charged with contempt of court for
violating a federal injunction against
the strike he served six months in jail
during that time Deb's read widely about
international socialism and emerged from
jail a firm believer in it originally a
Democrat he had served two terms in the
Indiana House of Representatives as a
Democrat Deb's was a founding member of
several socialist political parties
socialism was never able to form a
single coherent political party in this
country as socialist leaders almost
entirely intellectuals endlessly split
over ideological minutiae there was
social democrats anarchists communists
syndicalists and many many more Deb's
joined the Socialist Party of America in
1901 a party formed that year from a
merger of the Social Democratic Party
and the socialist Labor Party he ran for
president on a stick at five times in
1912 he received nine hundred and five
thousand votes fully six percent of the
total vote in 1920 he won 3.4 percent of
the vote although he was in jail for
Sedition at the time the Socialist Party
was adamantly opposed to American
participation in World War one and Deb's
had spoken out in favor of resisting the
draft sentenced to 10 years President
Warren Harding commuted the sentence to
time served in December of 1921 after
Deb's had served nearly three years in
jail after the collapse of the Czarist
regime in Russia and the subsequent
takeover by the Bolsheviks along with
this country's entry into World War one
the United States experienced the first
of the two 20th century read scares
there were reasons for these scares
there were numerous attempts some
successful to bomb people and property
the Washington House of Woodrow Wilson's
Attorney General Mitchell Palmer was
badly damaged by a bomb in June 1919
although Palmer himself was not
seriously hurt
and in September 1920 a whole wagonload
of dynamite blew up in front of the
morgan bank on Wall Street killing 38
and injuring
hundreds 143 of them severely windows
were blown out four blocks around the
facade of the Morgan Bank was scarred by
the explosion and the bank decided not
to repair the damage leaving it as a
sort of stigmata of capitalism it's
still there by the way a minor Wall
Street tourist attraction but the fear
generated by the Red Scare was far
greater than the actual threat hundreds
of aliens were deported including such
well-known ones as Emma Goldman and
Alexander Berkman who had tried to
assassinate the industrialist Henry Clay
Frick by one of those wonderful
coincidence of history so full of the
day he was deported was a day that Henry
Clay Frick died of natural causes
and Burton said at least he left the
country before I did while the socialist
party never came anywhere close to
winning a presidential race it had
electoral success at the local and
congressional levels after the election
of 1920 put five socialists in the New
York State Assembly they were summarily
suspended and then expelled they all ran
in special elections and were re-elected
but again denied their seats the
Communist Party of the United States was
founded in 1919 after the Russian
Revolution as they split off from Deb's
and Socialist Party of America unlike
Deb's of socialists it supported the
dictatorship of the proletariat wishes
to say the dictatorship of
self-appointed fiduciaries for the
proletarian it was deeply involved in
the American labor movement and through
a variety of front organizations
influenced many prominent people during
the Great Depression membership grew to
fifty five thousand at least according
to the CD USA but it was from the first
largely funded by and took orders from
the Soviet Union immediately after World
War Two broke out in September 1939 for
instance the Communist Party's newspaper
The Daily Worker began a long and
frequent series of editorials demanding
that this country stay out of the war
but on June 23rd 1941 the paper without
even
noting its about-face began demanding
the immediate entrance of the United
States into the war what had caused it
to change its editorial minds Nazi
Germany invaded the Soviet Union on June
22nd 1941 this convinced many that the
Communist Party of the United States was
not a genuine American political party
but a foreign agent non-communist
socialism's political popularity waned
in the 1920s in this country while
increasing in Europe both Britain and
France elected socialist governments in
1924 but Norman Thomas received only 2%
of the vote in the election of 1932
despite the country being in the depths
of the Great Depression while there was
widespread fear that capitalism and even
democracy would not survive New Deal
programs and especially the GI Bill of
Rights in 1944 proved the death knell of
socialism in America by subsidizing both
college education and homeownership the
GI Bill lifted millions into the middle
class with financial assets such as real
estate in other words the proletariat
became capitalist but the same time so a
new Red Scare thanks to the onset of the
Cold War people like Senator Joseph
McCarthy and the house on American
Activities Committee hounded people
before television cameras but found
relatively few actual communists while
ruining many lives and careers finally
in 1954 Senator McCarthy overplayed his
hand was censured by the Senate and the
second Red Scare began to fade away
while socialism disappeared as a
political force after World War two its
last gasp was probably the presidential
campaign of Henry Wallace in 1948
conservatives have worried about at what
point the social safety net ends and
latter-day socialism begins the
Democratic Party has moved markedly
leftward in the last few years and today
we are once again hearing calls from the
far left for socialist policies such as
Medicare for all and the Galit Aryan
policies such as a punitive well
tax on those who have been excessively
successful britain tried this tactic in
the labour government of clement attlee
after world war ii when the top income
tax rate in britain was 104 percent in
other words you were fined for creating
too much wealth that goes a long way to
explaining why Britain's economic
recovery after the war was so sluggish
senator Bernie Sanders himself a
millionaire who owns three houses says
that no one should be worth a billion
dollars
and would impose an eight percent tax on
the very very rich most of whom by the
way made their own fortunes seventy
percent of the Forbes 400 are self-made
men and women and no one of course is
any poorer because of the digital mega
fortunes that have been created in the
last 40 years enriching the rich by a
misery ting the poor is very poor public
policy just asked louis xvi becoming
super rich as Jeff Bezos has by giving
everybody a better and cheaper way to
shop made all of us richer ideologues
like Bernie Sanders he had his honeymoon
in Soviet Union please remember a
Stephen Sondheim once wrote I've been to
Moscow
it's very gay well anyway on the first
of May these ideologues are often
invincibly ignorant of the most basic
economics not only what a wealth tax be
extremely hard and expensive to
administer he would have devastating
effects on the entire American economy
and the American population if say Jeff
Bezos had to pay eight percent of his
net worth and taxes every year he would
have to sell eight percent of his vast
holdings of Amazon stock that of course
would cause the price of Amazon stock to
drastically decline indeed just the
market's anticipation of the sale would
cause it to decline costing Bezos far
more than 8 percent of his net worth an
Amazon stock is held not just by Jeff
Bezos but directly or indirectly by
millions of middle-class Americans in
their 401
hey accounts IRAs pension funds and
annuity accounts about two-thirds of
corporate stock today is held not like
plutocrats but by ordinary Americans
multiply Jeff Bezos as woes under a
wealth tax by those of the other six
hundred and twenty billionaires in the
country today and you would have a stock
market crash that would be worse than
1929 so a wealth tax while sticking it
to the Forbes 400 would also stick it to
just about everyone in this room
not to mention Hillsdale colleges
endowment fund I expected these policies
will get exactly nowhere the wealth tax
is after all almost certainly
unconstitutional as it is a direct tax
that could not be apportioned among the
states according to population you could
also make a good case that it is a bill
of attainder after all
Forbes magazine will supply you with a
list of the six hundred and twenty-one
billionaires in this country the
overwhelming majority of Americans
celebrate capitalist success not the cry
it like Bernie Sanders and Elizabeth
Warren and do not want to kill the
capitalist goose that has laid so very
many golden eggs for so many people they
understand instinctively thanks to those
risk-taking entrepreneurial genes they
inherited that socialism to borrow a
phrase from George Orwell is an idea so
stupid that only an intellectual could
believe it
the United States is still very stony
ground for socialism thank you very much
[Applause]
Thank You mr. Gordon we now have time
for some Q&A if you have a question
please make your way to the microphone
in the aisle the the one thing you
brought up or at least touched on
tangentially it was income inequality
what how do you feel about the concept
of cooperative
does that give capitalism a bit of a
safety valve I know it's work I mean in
a small sense it's part of our economy
cooperative structures I mean a
corporation is a cooperative structure
people come together under defined set
of rules in hopes of making more money
collectively than they could make
individually I mean so there's nothing
wrong with cooperative ventures many of
the people were in that one to do it
that way that's fine but the income
inequality every time you have serious
new technology you have a sudden
inflorescence of new fortunes that are
larger than the old ones were in 1827 a
young British writer coined the word
millionaire in order to describe not the
old aristocracy who wealth is based on
land but the new industrialists who were
much richer usually in terms of cash the
aristocrats are all through cash poor or
land poor as they call it and that by
the way that young writer went on to
another profession his name was Benjamin
Disraeli it happened again in the late
19th century with railroads than
automobiles and what have you now it is
happening with with digital technology
fortunes that were simply inconceivable
even 40 years ago then 1982 was the
first year of the Forbes 400 and you
needed 82 million dollars to make the
list and the richest guy was a guy named
Ludwig who nobody remembers anymore who
was worth I think it was 2.1 billion
today
you need to 0.1 billion to get onto the
Forbes list
there are about 200 American
billionaires not rich enough to make
that list now nobody's gotten poorer
because of these new fortunes this is
wealth Usos created it wasn't taken
you know something but Elizabeth Warren
thinks you know capitalism is a you know
an easy road am like poker we're for
every winner you have to have a loser
that's know we are all winners we are
all and anybody who's ever bought
something from Amazon or use Twitter or
you know found out where the hell you
were Thor the GPS on your cell phone we
are we are all winners there's no losers
which is you know wish people could just
get that through their heads I think
they actually understand it but they do
politically you know politicians lie
like rugs yeah really two questions one
quickly when the polls are mentioned
people between the eight ages of 18 and
25 fifty percent say they would like to
live in a socialist country do they
really understand what socialist means
that they understand that it the
government is the employer is
controlling are they just economically
illiterate and secondly could you kept
come in on capitalism in China I think
an awful lot of those 18 to 24 year olds
went to propaganda mills masquerading as
universities
they just obviously they don't
understand economic they'd understand
human nature I mean that's why socialism
can't work because of human nature
because we are self-interested and we
pursue our self-interest and you can't
people can't stop doing that and you
know lot of people think the
self-interest is is greed no it's not I
mean mother Teresa was self-interested
and what made her happy was spending her
life in the slums of Calcutta
what made Jeff Bezos happy was making
160 billion dollars and as for
capitalism in China China is a very
weird hybrid at this moment it is
capitalist in some ways but of course it
is a complete tyranny and others and
there's still huge state enterprises
most of which are very inefficient of
state enterprises tend to be and they
keep getting bucked up by the Chinese
government I don't think that's a stable
system in the long run and China
you know remember you can't trust
Chinese statistics they make them up
just like the Soviet Union did there's a
lot of unrest if you don't hear about
because of reporters reported they
suddenly find themselves no longer in
China but only about I think it's 65% of
the Chinese population is Han Chinese
the rest are all you know we Gers out in
seek yang man shoes up in Manchuria
there's all kinds of ethnic minorities
in China and many of them are not happy
now China has got firm control I mean
it's they're not gonna go gentle into
that good night I promise you but I
don't think in the long term you can
have this capitalist tyranny sustained
but with mules we will see my question
relates to the last gentleman you
mentioned that socialism so far has had
a stony ground in the United States with
the plurality of Millennials embracing
socialism or appearing to embracing
socialism do you find that a little bit
of an alarming statistic it's very
alarming but I think once they get out
into the real world they'll you know
they'll probably have to
wise up I mean I just show me a
socialist economy that has been
successful
there aren't any so why should we have a
socialist economy here we've had the
most successful economy in the history
of the world so let's get rid of that
that idea that works and get one that
has a proven track record of failure
it's just you know the mind boggles your
talk I was wondering you mentioned
earlier that there was an experiment on
the East Coast
of a socialist like a community that did
work and they still survived for 50
years why is that it's a very small
community and people are free to come
and go and so people they try it out for
a couple of years and they move on and
other people you know move in and I
think it's you know it's it's not a
tyranny it's you know it was people are
free to come and go they're not forced
to be there and they can go outside it
and earn money on the outside I mean
they're there they're free people who
choose to live in this very small
community and do things together
and I think I think in the other I think
there's 60 70 people live on that place
and that smaller group can do very well
just like you know hunter-gatherer
groups and they you know the Paleolithic
did very well
potentially it was the same kind of
system
can you comment on our fiat currency and
its perceived stability in our
capitalistic economy can you comment on
our fiat currency stability and how you
think that might impact our capitalistic
economy okay well every country in the
world now has fiat currencies and what
keeps them honest is the currency
trading market which trades around five
trillion dollars a day and in the night
early 1980s the president of France
Francois meet their own tried a
socialist agenda he nationalized the
French banks and on and on and on the
currency market tanked the French
currency to the point where MIT and Ron
have no alternative but to back off and
that's what we got rid of inflation in
the 1970s inflation roared in this
country at one in 1980 the prime rate
was 20% which is you know really awesome
but then the currency market got big
enough we've got globalized enough so
that we can act as a single unit
basically and that's what keeps
politicians from printing too much of
the stuff and you know occasionally
there are countries like Argentina which
does it over and over and over again and
then they keep reelecting para nice days
over and over and over again it's really
Argentina's a wonderful country but
their politics is just bizarre makes
French politics look good
I think you know our money is under
control at the moment and because you
know also we have a if Congress could
print money then we'd be in serious
trouble but they can't only the Fed can
do that so that's one of the Hamilton
said you know don't let politicians
anywhere near the power of printing
money one of the most effective enemies
of capitalism are the capitalists
themselves Bill Gates is giving away his
money by the billions trying to buy
himself a mother teresa halo why are
they doing that what is their view of
morality that they considered but mother
Teresa would help the few people out of
the gutter better than the people that
are in ithaca Herbert Hoover famously
said that the trouble with capitalism is
capitalist and he's right because
capitalists are all too happy from many
of them are to become rent seekers if
they can get away with it and in this
time in this world they they can very
frequently in the government the
government gives some special little
fiddles on the side the tax code is is
corrupt from page one to page 56,000 and
half of it is literally little quiet
fiddles two people who make big
political contributions but you know I'm
afraid again that's human nature to you
know if you can get a cheap buck you're
gonna take it and who can blame them so
we just said yeah we're human that we
don't know we are we are not angels as
James Madison so astutely pointed out
and that's true a capitalist and it's
true politicians and it's true of
university professors
even the occasional speaker so according
to the world health care organization
like the the American health care is
around
I think 36 on the list was like the
French health care and like Canadian
health care in front of the the American
one so I was wondering why do you think
socialized health care is like this can
be higher up on that list than the
American one if like they should be more
innovative and more functional there
there's two things here one is
statistics in many European countries a
baby that dies very shortly after birth
is listed as a stillbirth whereas in
this country if a baby is born
struggling they move heaven and earth to
keep it alive and that they lose it it's
an infant mortality so we have a higher
infant mortality rate than Britain and
France and other countries do but that's
a statistical thing the other thing is
the American healthcare system is a
complete mess I mean it's the best
system in the world but it's in terms of
you know its ability to cure the
incurable but it's economically it is it
is terrible to communicating there's no
price transparency in the United States
I mean you go to a hospital and say huh
I need my knee replaced how much would
you charge they won't tell you and then
you get this bill is this thick and we
have one aspirin tablet $2.50 and and
what have you if and Donald Trump is
actually trying to get them to do this
and they're both the insurance companies
and the hospitals are fighting tooth and
nail to prevent it but if they were
forced to post their prices everywhere
and so every Hospital had to say we'll
do a knee transplant for X now
immediately what would happen the
competition would force people to lower
their prices and we could drain at least
two trillion dollars a year out of
American healthcare simply by making
them post their
prices and the American Medical
Association the American Hospital
Association's are extremely potent
lobbies in Washington but that would go
a long way to solving elfric we have too
many hospitals in this country very hard
politically to close them
what we need is more specialty hospitals
like Marone Memorial sloan-kettering in
New York the great cancer hospital and
then Urgent Care places and then small
towns need maybe you know small
hospitals and somebody's really sick and
they ship them off to a major
metropolitan area but we have many many
too many hospital beds at the moment is
also very expensive John thank you for
your talk
one thing I would recommend to everybody
as they read his books starting with
Hamilton's blessing it is a fantastic
work as for a question my question has
to do with inflation how come we don't
have it even though we've printed so
much money is it because of our
incredible productivity or is it bad
data that we're not actually seeing it
being reported correctly one reason is a
digitalization of the economy as
enormous efficiencies are built into
that I mean so it's you know as I say
Amazon again I'm always talking about
Amazon I've only go there two or three
times a week
they're able to sell things at a much
lower cost than brick-and-mortar because
there's such enormous economies of scale
and so in Walmart to Walmart is is
economic power so that it can force its
suppliers to really cut things to the
bone and so that's what as I think is
kept inflation under check in the last
from this revolution that we've been
undergoing for the last 30 odd years use
the mic in West Virginia 22 years ago is
two-and-a-half times the cost now yep so
that's inflation isn't it no you have a
much better car today
well they last a lot longer than they
used to they have all kinds of wonderful
gadgets like GPS I noticed I got in the
car this morning to get to the airport
and the car it automatically changed the
clock to daylight saving time I know
that's really neat cuz I never remember
to do that and I mean giving cars are
pretty mature technology basically but I
bought my first computer in 1986 it had
a 12-inch black-and-white cathode ray
monitor a dot matrix printer which was
terribly noisy and only did one typeface
I had eight Meg's of RAM and 20 megabyte
hard drive which was thought 1986 that
was pretty sexy in 2019 terms they
caught dollars it cost around $7,000
today I have a 24 inch hi-def flat
screen full color monitor I have a
inkjet printer I have eight gigabytes of
RAM and I have a terabyte of hard drive
that's 50,000 times as big as my first
hard drive 30 odd years ago and of
course the whole set
cost around $1,200 so think that's a
technology that's rapidly advancing and
so the prices are rapidly collapsing
whereas automobiles are you know they've
been around since you know 1896 when
Mercedes Mercedes was the daughter I
forget the UM the man's name who
invented the carburetor which was the
last little gizmo needed to make the car
work carburetors of course the long
disappeared so I think that's mostly
innocent as the we just get better and
cheaper making these things and they're
better things to you know I have used to
be a car that lasted a hundred thousand
miles even if it took good care of it
that was good now I'm two hundred
thousand miles is by no means unheard of
we have done we have time for one more
question
yeah I'm curious if you identify any
inconsistency or in congruence between
the writes simultaneous rejection of
socialism on the far left with their
embrace of you know protectionist
policies at the same time because a lot
of people you know might classify those
is the type of rent-seeking that you're
just imagining a few moments ago all
manufacturers think that their supplier
should be highly competitive but their
customers should have no choices
again welcome to human nature I mean so
protection is a bad idea just of itself
but they're you know they're always
gonna have tariffs because of some
reason sometimes we have you know
strategic reasons for having tariffs I
mean we have to have a know an airplane
industry in this country you can't be a
great power without an airplane industry
but it also it's you can use it as a
political tactic because Trump is using
against China right now but high tariffs
never work well they because again what
tariff is a tax so it drives up the
price for everybody else and allows
manufacturers in this country to be less
efficient they're hidden behind tarath
walls they don't have to work hard and
nobody works any harder than they have
to to accomplish their goals
you know lions don't chase the fast
zebras to get supper they they chase the
slow ones who taste just as good
I have it on the best authority thank
you very much
[Applause]